um yeah this game is crazy crystal duda
he loves to entertain us
well now the king can step to the side
and uh get out of the way
of the queen and now the bishop can find
another diagonal to hound on
just to round off the pawn okay well
wesley has
again not following the howell school of
advice he has pushed the pawn
and very bold stuff um i mean i really
love your advice
just build up the time before you before
you make committal decisions
yeah i've been in these kind of high
pressure
time situations many well countless
times in my career so i know that uh
sometimes it's better just not to commit
just wow spending has wesley so just
blunted a bishop he's blundered his
bishop he missed that check
well oh wow look at that wesley so he's
we saw it immediately he's missed a
double attack black in check and now
he's bishop attacked as well
he's lost a bishop that's a huge blunder
that's um yeah yeah he just panicked
there
that's um that that was just uh it
wasn't it wasn't yeah greed
greed it was a case of that he saw the
bishop
was on priest and before the thought had
even formulated itself you know the hand
had already played it
this is a common scenario in
online chess devastating for wesley
seoul
that probably now will lose this game
yeah look at that he was playing for the
win a moment ago he was the one taking
the risks
and it was justified he'd outplayed jan
christophe duda suddenly everything was
going in black's favor
but he just got greedy at the wrong
moment like that's why we say
we say look for checks first that's the
first thing you should look for in every
position
he didn't look for his opponents and uh
i mean i've been the victim of this so
many times i see
the idea and the hand has already played
it before i've even had time to register
that it was the worst blunder in the
world yeah and we did see a funny moment
actually when white